more than 28 million Americans
reportedly have already cast their
ballots in this election over the past
week we've seen massive early voting
lines in multiple States part of what
what's expected to be a record turnout
Manuel borz is in Miami Manny early
voting is just getting underway there
what are you
seeing we are all see already seeing the
lines uh Anthony you can see behind me
may be able to make out some of the
people here uh but what you can't see
because the sun is really not that
bright yet is the fact that this line
extends around the corner and all the
way down the block and people have been
standing out here for hours now braving
sporadic downpours this is Florida after
all many told us that they wanted to get
here early to cast their ballot before
the start of their work
[Music]
day enthusiasm is reaching a fever pitch
in the Sunshine
State for both president Trump and Joe
Biden winning Florida could signal a
path to the White House we win Florida
and it's all over and turnout is already
booming really excited about what we're
about to do in two weeks nearly 2 and a
half million people have already cast
their votes by mail in the state that's
already come close to surpassing the
number from the entire 2016 election but
it's not just Florida turnout is
shattering records across the country
According to some estimates voters have
so far cast more than six times the
amount of ballots compared to the same
time period four years ago that's led to
excessively long lines from North
Carolina to Louisiana to Texas which has
nearly 2 million more registered voters
than it did in 2016 but as with past
elections it's Florida getting a lot of
attention the president has been at
least 13 times this year Biden at least
three president Trump won the swing
state in 2016 by just under 113,000
votes but so far Democrats here have
turned in nearly 500,000 more ballots
David Becker is the executive director
of the center for election Innovation
and research does the president casting
doubt on the Integrity of mail in
ballots do you think that's had some
Republicans say let's wait until we can
do it in person the president's uh false
claims about uh male voting and and
questions about the Integrity of male
voting have made only his own voters
doubt that very important option
and if you need another indication of
just how important Florida is to both
campaigns take a look at the advertising
dollars the two campaigns have spent
close to a combined $158 million on
advertising in the state with more on
the way Gail all right Manny thank you I
just hope whoever wins Christmas season
is not cancelled canceled a lot of stuff
please don't cancel Christmas too